[Musique]
c'est une première parce qu'on a déjà vu
ici au Sénégal des ateliers de graves
des êtres des sessions de
Life painting des choses comme ça
c'était juste des moments
fixes pour partager avec les jeunes
partager son expérience mais là nous ce
qu'on a voulu faire c'est avoir un
bastion avoir un endroit où on peut
vraiment partager notre expérience avec
d'autres jeunes qui sont passionnés du
graffiti en fait
[Musique]
on a ces prises de position assez
radicale par rapport à des questions par
rapport à des points de vue par rapport
à une vision de la chose l'exemple la
plus récente c'était le mieux du
président Macky Sall qui tirait sur
citoyen sénégalais qui a qui a fait le
tour du monde en fait et que voilà
qu'ils ont effacé une autre temps après
sa réalisation parce que on a compris
que l'art avait cet impact là dans les
consciences et que nos gouvernement ont
forcément peur de ce message que porte
cet art actuel
[Musique]